Oh, wow.
The Parkes radio telescope,
here in Australia,
is most famous for receiving pictures
from the Apollo 11 moonwalk.
But it's still in near-constant use
for astronomy and scientific research.
Now, it's a maintenance day here today,
which is why I'm allowed to be here
on the surface of the dish.
And the dish is about to tilt over,
nearly all the way
to touching the ground,
and I'm going to be here
while it happens.
I'm going for a ride!
But that would be a lot of
very slow, boring footage
of me just awkwardly standing
and sitting here
as my world tilts over.
So while that's happening,
let me show you how I got here.
I'm going to be filming this awkwardly.
We've got John here
who's going to show me around.
We've got Jack behind the camera.
Let's go see a telescope!
- Yeah. Let's go in, Tom, and see
what it's like inside it.
- You can tell it was built
in the '60s and '70s, can't you?
Big asbestos warning.
- This is the ground floor where we
have the air conditioning units
that help keep all our electronics cool.
- And the astronomers, presumably!
- And the astronomers too.
Just behind Jack here,
we have the most important
room in the building,
which is the astronomer's kitchen.
If they do visit,
they can stay on site.
But over the last 10 years,
we've switched to a
remote observing regime
where people can log in
over the internet to observe.
So we have fewer and fewer
astronomers visiting now.
But let's go on upstairs
and have a look in
the main control room.
So, follow me on up.
[warning siren]
- This is so weird, because...
the clouds are rotating!
I know the dish is rotating,
but I cannot see anything.
- So, this is the old control room.
The old control desk that was
recreated for the film, The Dish,
used to be located about there.
But in 1982, it was decommissioned
and replaced by a computerized desk
that used the PDP-11 computers.
It doesn't crash very often,
because it doesn't have
an operating system.
It just stays up very reliably.
And so we still use it to
drive the dish around
and to point the telescope too.
If it's not broken,
we're not fixing it!
The radio waves coming down
from the stars,
they're reflected off the
parabolic surface of the dish,
and they're brought to the focus
where the radio waves
are concentrated.
We can typically collect a
few terabytes of data a day,
but with the new receivers that
we're commissioning later this year,
we'll be looking at maybe
nine terabytes an hour.
The telescope itself is an
extremely sensitive radio detector,
because the energies that we're
collecting from the stars
are incredibly weak.
If I was to release the feather
and let it slowly just drift
to the floor here like this,
the energy that feather expended
when it struck the floor was more
than all the energy ever collected
by every radio telescope ever built,
in terms of the astronomical data.
And so that's why radio telescopes
have to be so large,
because you want as large a
collecting area as possible.
Any electronic devices will transmit
radio waves that could very easily
overwhelm the really feeble signals
we're trying to detect,
such as mobile phones-
- Such as these wireless mics, by the way!
It's a maintenance day.
I got special permission for these!
- That's right. A lot of this tech here
we've designed ourselves,
but we also have other equipment
that we buy off the shelf,
and then we have to
put them in shielded cabinets,
because they're not really designed
to be radio-quiet, so to speak.
A mobile telephone on the moon's surface,
400,000 kilometers away,
would be one of the brightest
radio sources in the sky for us.
So if we can detect it
from the moon,
we have no trouble detecting it
from the car park!
We refer to this as the
master control panel.
If I was to turn this off here,
you can see it's on remote,
it'll be on computer control
so that people off-site can log in,
take control,
and move the telescope.
But if I was to put it onto
local and master control,
I'll be able to move it using these dials,
up and down, left and right.
- Wait, the dials still work?
- Oh, yeah.
[warning siren]
Oh, okay. Gravity is changing direction.
I-- We got to walk this way.
I guess we got to
stay horizontal here.
I'm not actually sure what
horizontal is anymore.
Am I still...?
No, I think I need
to go further.
I'm not horizontal yet.
I've got no reference frame.
I can't see the horizon.
I can't see anything.
This is dizzying!
- Because we observe
remotely now, often,
there's nobody in the tower
when we're observing.
And so we need a way to make sure
the telescope's safe at all times.
So we have this device called the
Telescope Protection System or TPS,
which monitors hundreds of
data points on the telescope.
And if it detects an issue
that might be a problem,
it immediately alerts us
using SMS messages, emails,
telex, everything.
And we can immediately descend
on the telescope,
see what's wrong,
and fix it.
And we have an anemometer,
as soon as the wind reaches
a certain critical speed,
that's when we say,
the winds are too high,
and we just stow the telescope.
Because essentially, the telescope's
just a giant beach umbrella.
- I mean, this thing's incredibly robust.
It's held up to significant
wind and weather.
- When it was commissioned
back in October 1961,
it was only intended to
operate for 20 years.
So we're now 41 years
over that.
And the reason for it is because
we've continually upgraded the telescope.
The most obvious upgrades have
been to the dish surface.
- I'm not going to do anything,
but I... suddenly,
I'm not walking on
the solid surface,
I'm walking on the mesh
of the dish,
and my brain is...
just about dealing with it?
- We're going up into the
dish surface here.
So we're first going up
through the spiral-
- Spiral staircase!
-spiral staircase in the
central column.
This central column is on a
separate foundation
to the rest of the building,
because at the top of this column
is the master equatorial,
the device that helps us point
the telescope accurately.
So we don't want that connected to
the rest of the building
because the vibrations will cause
the pointings of the telescope to be out.
So come on up.
- So all the cables here are
transmission cables?
- That's right.
Yeah, they're bringing signals
down from the focus cabin,
and also,
we send other commands up to operate
the equipment and power it, and so on.
Okay.
- I just looked over and there's
a horizon all of a sudden!
- We're now going to go through
the door down to the azimuth track.
- Right. Okay. Oh, yeah. I just looked up.
There's a telescope up there!
- Before we go all the way down,
you can see this is the twister room.
The cables coming down from the
focus cabin come down here first.
There are two counter-rotating rings.
So as the dish rotates in azimuth,
they counter-rotate,
so they take up the
slack and release it,
so that the cables don't get
twisted and tangled or anything like that.
- Oh, that's very clever.
- So this level is what we
call the azimuth track,
and this is the actual
azimuth track.
And if you look here,
you can see it's
sitting on four rollers,
but only two are driven.
On this track, we move it
left and right like this.
But you can see in
the center there,
there's nothing actually
holding it down.
It's just pivoted there.
It's just the sheer weight of the structure
that keeps the telescope grounded.
- Because everything from this level
on up weighs a thousand tonnes
or the equivalent of
three fully-laden jumbo jets.
- Yeah, okay!
All right.
- So when they built the
telescope back in the '50s,
they didn't have computers that could do
the coordinate conversions fast enough.
So instead, Barnes Wallis,
a really famous British engineer,
he came up with this device,
essentially said it's an optical telescope.
And because that's the polar axis,
once you point the optical telescope
to the position you want on the sky,
you only have to move it at a
constant rate around the polar axis
so that you could then
follow the object
smoothly across the sky.
- You're adjusting for the earth's rotation
by just rotating something
at the same angle
in the opposite direction.
- In the opposite direction.
And this was the secret
to the telescope's success,
we were able to point
the telescope
very, very accurately on the sky.
In fact, it was so successful
that all subsequent large,
single-dish antennas
employed a master equatorial
up until about the 1990s,
when the microprocessors
were small enough and fast enough
to do the coordinate conversions
on the fly.
Before we go up,
let's have a little walk
around the super structure
just under the dish.
So, here we go.
- You're walking around here
a lot more casually than I am!
- Oh, okay!
You can see here,
this is a great view.
You can see out towards the east
where we have the Hervey Ranges
that shield us from the
radio emissions
from the larger population centers
further east.
- Right.
- This is one of the reasons
why it was chosen.
It's very radio-quiet.
- All right.
So, next stop...
- Yeah.
- Surface.
We'll go around.
We'll keep going around,
and then we'll end up
where we started.
- If you just turn the camera
around that way for a moment,
that's where I was
standing a moment ago,
was in the middle of that dish.
This ride I'm taking
isn't just a gimmick.
It's called a "hayride"
sometimes,
but it turns out that's a term
that was invented by Americans
for a film that was shot here
more than 20 years ago.
The folks at Parkes actually just
call this "riding the dish",
and they use it to get
heavy equipment
in and out of the central part.
Because it's a lot easier
to let the dish do the lifting
instead of trying to actually
lug bulky gear
through all the corridors
and stairwells inside.
Two hands on the railing...
and we're down!
Thank you very much, folks!
Thank you, Jack!